now I want to show you a really useful
manual skill that you can use when you
have voltages that look like
Exponential's and we're going to talk
about this exponential curve here that's
generated as part of the natural
response of this RC circuit and we
worked out that the voltage across here
this voltage V of T on the capacitor its
natural response is equal to V 0 v
naught times e to the minus T over RC
this value V naught is the starting
voltage that our input source provides
and then it immediately steps down to
zero and this circuit then does its
natural response we get a current coming
out of this capacitor flowing around in
a circle like this and that's the
natural response of this RC circuit I
want to look at the properties of this
function right here it's got some
interesting properties I'll write it
right here V naught e to the minus T
over RC so first thing we can look at is
this V naught value that's this value
here this is V naught and this
particular chart V naught was equal to
one volt
that's what originally charged up to and
now we want to look at this point right
here right when it goes through time
equals zero and the and the curve starts
to drop we know how high it is it's V
naught volts hi what I want to look at
now is what's what's the slope right at
this point
the slope of a curve is the derivative
of a curve evaluated at this time at
time equals zero let's take the
derivative of our function right here
so it's D DT V naught e to the minus T
over RC and that equals V naught and the
RC comes down minus 1 over RC comes down
minus 1 over RC e to the minus T over RC
and that's the derivative of this
exponential for all time so now we
evaluate it at T equals 0 and we get V
naught over RC and there's a minus sign
and it's e to the I plug in 0 for T it's
e to the 0 and e to the 0 is 1 so that
equals the slope at time equals 0 that
equals the slope at time equals 0 so
that's the value right here that's what
that slope looks like that tangent line
to the curve ok now the next thing I
want to do is actually take this line
and extend it all the way down until it
crosses this axis until it crosses the
time axis and the next question we're
going to ask is what is this point right
here what's that point let me move up a
little bit so now we have a line we've
defined a line that means we have an
equation of a line so the equation of a
line is y equals slope times X plus B B
is the intercept on the voltage axis M
is the slope I can plug in my values
here for our chart Y is the voltage axis
we know what the slope is that's right
is sitting right here it's minus V
naught over RC and we multiplied by time
and we add the y intercept or the volt
voltage intercept which we know is V
naught
possibly not all right and now what I
want to do is find out at what time what
time does voltage equal zero for this
orange line so we're going to plug in
zero for volts and work out what time is
zero equals V nought times 1 over RC and
don't lose the minus sign times t plus 1
if I divide both sides by V naught I get
zero on this side and this term on this
side so I can say zero equals minus 1
over RC times t plus 1 and we want to
isolate T so we'll take the one on the
other side and multiply by RC so one
more step minus 1 equals minus 1 over RC
times T and in the end we come up with T
equals RC
t equals RC is that time right there
that's how many seconds after the step
that this line hits the the time axis
and notice something here there's no
mention of V not in here
there's no V not there's no V not it's
not here and it divided out in this step
back here it's one of our steps it
disappeared going from this step to this
step here so independent of how high
this thing starts it can be higher it
can be low then the slope of this line
always great goes right through the time
equals RC and one more thing we want to
work out is at time equals RC what is
the value of the exponential what is
what is this voltage what is this
voltage here when time equals RC so we
can use our equation again we can plug
into our equation and find out how to do
that if I go back to V equals V naught e
to the minus T over RC and this time
we're going to plug in our C right here
for this value here and find out what V
is so V equals V naught e e to the minus
RC over RC or equals V naught e to the
minus 1 now the value of e is roughly
equal to 2.7 and the value of 1 over e
is roughly equal to 0.37 or another way
I could say that is 37% so in the end
this voltage right here is about 37%
a v-not that's that value right there
so these that's two little things we're
going to tuck a tuck away in our head
the time for that line to hit the time
axis is our C if I want to know the
value of where the exponential actually
is at time equals our C it's roughly 37%
of where it started from okay that's the
basic idea and in the next video I'll
show you how to use these ideas to
sketch Exponential's really quickly